welcome back to the Ingram angle while
the media obsess over Cova and largely
peaceful protests a new crop of GOP
congressional candidates are on the rise
and they aren't what you'd expect two of
them join us tonight first up is Madison
Cawthorne he's a 24-year old who won a
big upset in last week's primary after
he beat the candidate president Trump
endorsed for North Carolina's 11th
district also with us
his former NFL player Burgess Owens who
beat three primary contenders to become
the nominee for Utah's 4th district
gentlemen thank you both for being with
us
Madison I want to start with you you
have an amazing story you could well be
the youngest congressman in the Capitol
but you shot you suffered a terrible
accident lost the use of your legs what
did you learn from that and did that
drive you at all to want to run for
Congress of course it didn't Raymond and
I thank you so much for having me on you
know my accident taught me the obvious
lessons you know I was won by the one
percent chance to live I was in a
hospital for over a year but I'd tell me
the obvious lessons of perseverance and
grit but you know it taught me something
else which I think the Republican Party
desperately needs and that's empathy
it's being able to look at somebody else
who might not look just like me and be
able to try and understand things from
their viewpoints so I absolutely think
you're right when you say there's a new
breed of candidates coming up I mean you
saw my victory is 66% with mr. Olens
victory with 43 and a half percent this
is a the Republican Party's coalescing
around warriors they want to send to
Washington DC to get rid of all this
cronyism in just the swamp Burgess you
could flip a seat for the GOP and you
said today that Democrats are frantic
that they're losing the black vote what
does your candidacy how does that change
the math here for the GOP well first of
all it's exciting to me to have
Kennedy's like Madison and across our
country we have a very special moment we
have a chance to for for a new Congress
to come in place 1920 of new freshmen
that are patriots not not not
politicians that love our country and
Ashley in the house now
see how a love America first leadership
looks like and we're there to replicate
that so I see this as very simply first
of all Americans across the board we do
not we don't take good for bullying
we don't take good for those who want to
destroy our nation our culture we stand
up and there's a Salomon majority going
right now and that's gonna end up
getting a house of Patriots they sent it
with more backbone and a president
finally has an opportunity to govern
without his hands timeout is back so I
would say America's stay optimistic the
next four years gonna be a true
renaissance because these guys evil
works as hard as before the dawn they
understand your bond to lose it and they
cannot stand this process of seeing all
their work for decades being taken away
by a president who loves our country and
I wouldn't the fight against bullies
Madison the media's convinced the best
path to victory for Republican
candidates is to socially distance
themselves from Donald Trump watch this
we are now just four months from the
election it may get some Republicans
cover to distance themselves a little
bit and to perhaps loosen this
president's hold on his party any
Republican that is currently elected is
having to answer for what the president
is doing they are trying to distance
themselves now Republican senators and
members of Congress are going to be
trying to survive and if that means
dropping Donald Trump you can bet
they'll do it Madison you actually
defeated a trump endorsed candidate in
North Carolina will you be running from
the leader of your party absolutely not
you know I've often times said that I by
no means believe that my victory was a
referendum on Donald Trump but you know
when the voters of Western North
Carolina who are very wise and
discerning just looked at both
candidates and looked at the situation
our country is in and we have the the
the difference could not be more clear
between my opponent and now the opponent
that mr. Olens is gonna be going up
against you know they want anarchy they
want to defund our police while we both
stand for law and order and we back up a
president who is willing to lead us back
from an entire an unprecedented time in
our country with Kovach 19 with race
relations and with this economy crisis
that were in if we distance herself from
Donald Trump I think we'll be doing
ourselves a great disservice Burgess I
want to show you what you're going to be
up against if you should arrive on
Capitol Hill this
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee we
understand that the disparities that are
so stark that a reflective of the
brutality or the cruelty the fundamental
injustice and humanity of slavery have
never been answered this is America's
responsibility to pay the American
government's responsibility to pay her
debt he's talking about reparations
there what would you tell her Burgess
well you listen to the voice of a
Marxist all right let me just say this
my great community I grew up in that was
the most competitive a minority in our
country 40 students and 60s was turned
upside down not by white assembly
supremacist but by black leaders like
the ones just heard from the Black
Caucus
the n-double-a-cp has done nothing
become wealthy off the misery of the
rate of the communities that they're
supposed to be protecting so I'm excited
because we have in at Madison people at
Madison and across the board we are
remarkable young freshmen coming in and
watch out these guys gonna be there for
the right reasons not to be politic
career career politicians not to be
lobbyists but they get our country back
because we love the culture we love our
nation we love our history and we're not
gonna apologize who we are and we get
this group back in place believe me guys
get ready and you'll see this guy's
going frantic by the way these these
black marks it's Dickensian Lorne
frantic Madison I only have 30 seconds
mark Meadows who had the seat that you
are seeking he endorsed your opponent
but you have a close relationship with
him he was your Speech and Debate coach
yes he was he definitely taught me how
to be able to rip apart in an argument
that's filled with fallacies and that's
all the Democrats have so you know
there's no hard feelings there he's been
very good to me my entire life
nominated me to the United States Naval
Academy so no hard feelings there but
you know just like mr. Owens is saying
we have a patriot revolution on the rise
and although that leaves far Follette
for enjoyment of these these marks this
is coming we're coming with a vengeance
and we're ready to fight thank you both
it is real quick go ahead Democrats and
independents listen to we're saying
we're all in this together we're
fighting for the same in game don't let
the left divide us let's do it to get
this thing done
guys gentlemen I thank you both for
being here and and for your efforts
we'll be watching you as the months roll
on here to Election Day